il y avait beaucoup de camions Swat qui passaient
très lentement ainsi que des voitures de police
entourant ma maison, nous savions donc
qu'ils regardaient et directement autour de ma
maison, puis tout à coup l'un des
camions SWAT s'est arrêté et a déchargé tous les
officiers et ils ont procédé à  allez dans mon
jardin et à ce moment-là, ils crient,
sortez les mains en l'air et
ils criaient pendant environ cinq minutes
et ils avaient leurs armes chargées, puis
finalement cinq minutes plus tard, Justin
est sorti les mains en l'air et il a crié
j'ai fini  et ils l'ont récupéré et l'
ont amené dans ma cour avant où il
s'est étendu et ils lui avaient l'arme
à feu, puis finalement ils l'ont
récupéré dans le camion SWAT et
le reste des officiers a inspecté ma
propriété pour d'autres armes à feu ou suspects potentiels